oui bonjour à tous ici jean rony martias
et je vous souhaite la bienvenue à
kapatakan cette semaine dans mon
reportage
j'avais envie de vous parler de jeunesse
de jeunesse autochtone encore une fois
mais de jeunesse autochtone d'un point
de vue d'autodétermination je sais pas
si vous avez vu passer la nouvelle la
semaine dernière mais la communauté
d'obedjiwan communauté attikamek adopter
donc sa loi de la protection sociale
attikameks d'obedjiwan est en fait cette
loi là et découle de la loi 6 92 c'est
une loi fédérale qui permet maintenant
aux communautés autochtones de se doter
de leurs propres lois donc de leur
propre système de protection de la
jeunesse donc ça c'est clairement une
avancée vers l'autodétermination des
premières nations puisque la communauté
d'obedjiwan tout comme d'autres
communautés sont en train de le faire au
québec et au canada mais sont en train
de développer leur propre système de
protection de la jeunesse donc qui soit
adaptée ea culturellement daté en plus
donc alors communauté à leur nation
évidemment il ya plusieurs enjeux qui
viennent avec l'adoption de lois ou ans
que dans l'élaboration de systèmes comme
celui que fait la communauté d'obedjiwan
est un des premiers enjeux mais c'est
celui de la porte est donc la portée
pour faire simple il ya des lois il au
québec au canada un peu partout dans le
monde qui ont différents types de portes
et donc les deux principaux sont surtout
des lois à portée territoriale donc ça
veut dire que la loi s'applique sur un
territoire donné et aux individus qui
sont présents sur ce territoire là est
de notre côté on aussi des lois qui sont
apportées personnel donc la porte et
personnel ça veut dire que s'applique
aux personnes peu importe de territoire
ou est ce que ces personnes se trouvent
donc l'enjeu que moi j'entrevois
par rapport à l'élaboration de lois de
protection de la jeunesse de l'apport
des premières nations c'est que c'est
loin bain et dépasse la portée
territoriale donc qu'elles deviennent
des lois à porter personnel et sommet
que c'est pas toujours évident donc si
on prend l'exemple la communauté
d'obedjiwan la loi et va s'appliquer de
façon très simple au territoire de la
communauté par contre on sait très bien
on a de plus en plus d'autochtones qui
habite maintenant en milieu urbain et
lorsque ce qui devient intéressant c'est
que les lois de vient apporter personnel
donc une personne autochtone qui ne
réside pas sur les territoires de sa
communauté puisse aussi se prévaloir de
la loi en question si jamais la faire
avec le système de protection de la
jeunesse est évidemment dans ce qui est
dit que la communauté d'obedjiwan qui
évite probablement que d'autres
communautés vont essayer de faire la
même chose c'est de créer des entend
donc je de dale coyne d'obedjiwan ce qui
se fait en ce moment c'est qu'ils sont
en négociations sont en pourparlers avec
des centres d'amitié autochtones pour
peut-être avoir des intervenants qu'ils
puissent aller offrir des services donc
à leurs membres qui habitent dans les
milieux urbains par contre c'est pas
c'est pas gagné d'avancé puisque c'est
pas toujours évident d'avoir juridiction
à l'extérieur de sa communauté quand
contente de loi autochtone mais
évidemment ce soit un enjeu leur sort
est lié au cours des prochaines années
parce que je pense que que les
communautés puis surtout les individus
gangrène beaucoup à ce que ces lois là
mais une porte et personnel un des
autres enjeux qu'on aura souri ben c'est
le financement de ces systèmes là en ce
moment dans le cas de la communauté
d'obedjiwan et bénéficie d'un
financement à peu près 35 millions pour
opérationnaliser son système de
protection de la jeunesse par contre on
sait très bien qu'on est au début
de ça la loi c'est 92 gouvernement
fédéral est adopté il ya environ deux
ans donc le les communautés à travers le
pays sont en train de développer leur
propre système est bien au fur et à
mesure que les systèmes se développeront
ben ça coûtera des frais des charges au
gouvernement pour financer ces systèmes
un des problèmes c'est que en ce moment
pour et sait pas c'est pas le cas pour
tous le mais une grande majorité des
systèmes qui sont en train de se
développer le sens à une échelle
communautaire donc d'une seule
communauté et pas nécessairement
l'échelle de nation ou à l'échelle de
regroupement de communautés autochtones
et celle au ksk que peut-être un jour ça
deviendra un hors jeu parce que au
québec on sait on a énormément
communauté autochtone un peu plus d'une
cinquantaine et ça ça veut dire que
imaginez si chacune des rives et des
communautés autochtones du québec
développé son propre système bass ed ça
génère des coûts quand même important et
qui devient intéressant c'est qu'en lieu
lieu il ya des regroupements peut-être
des alliances qui se font entre les
différentes communautés ou entre les
différentes nations pour offrir des
services communs à l'ensemble de ses
membres je pense des fois que la façon
de fonctionner du gouvernement fédéral a
peut-être eu pour effet de diviser
parfois les communautés puis de faire en
sorte qu'ils aient développé des projets
en silo donc chacune pour soi
par contre je pense que on sent de plus
en plus qu'une volonté de la part des
communautés des premiers rangs des
premières nations à travailler ensemble
entre autres pour couvrir peut pas être
les services qui pourraient être offerts
en milieu urbain donc je pense que le
sabre est une belle avenue une belle
réflexion endroit parce qu'on sait dans
les centres urbains mais on ne dit on
est des individus des autochtones qui
émane de différentes communautés donc
c'est là que ça devient intéressant de
peut-être avoir des services communs
pour les individus qui habitent en
milieu urbain et finalement le dernier
range rue identifiée mais c'est celui
que en ce moment le gouvernement du
québec est en train de contester la
validité de la loi ces 92 et ça ça
pourrait être un enjeu parce que en ce
moment la loisne n'est pas invalidée
donc en fait ce que le gouvernement du
québec dit c'est que la loi fédérale
elle empiète sur les compétences de la
province donc si un jour
donc une cour invalide
la validité de la loi 6 92 qu'est ce qui
a pu bien dehors des lois qui auront été
élaboré par les communautés autochtones
est-ce qu'on va tomber dans le néant est
ce que si le système de protection de la
jeunesse du québec qui va prendre le
relais à ce moment là donc beaucoup de
questionnement qu'est ce qui adviendra à
ce moment là et je pense que derrière
soyez un peu une guerre d'égos un
évidemment entre les gouvernements
ont-ils gouvernement provincial et le
gouvernement fait d'erreurs et je pense
que il ya clairement une opportunité
leur à ce moment ci pour le gouvernement
provincial de peut-être démontrer sa
bonne foi par rapport aux premières
nations en ne contestant pas cette voie
là et en appuyant la démarche des
communautés dans leur autodétermination
on sait les relations parfois été
tendues entre le gouvernement du québec
et les communautés autochtones
de la province donc ça pourrait être
intéressant peut-être de voir le québec
comme un vrai allié dans ce dossier là
qui concerne les jeunes maintenant nos
communautés en milieu urbain donc
c'était mes réflexions de la semaine
j'espère que vous avez apprécié et je
vous dis à bientôt pour un reportage